il ya eu également stars à domicile a
été une révolution dans le
divertissement
c'était bien ça restait alors on va
t'emmener d'après flavie flament wii qui
y avait la chance et le privilège
d'abord un travail de la russie 1-0 gré
en tant qu'animateur il mérimée produits
et h 30
franchement c'était un c'était une rolls
royce comme on dit et moi j'ai vécu de
l'intérieur le l'enfant de cette
émission c'était un phénomène faut
rappeler le contexte où on allait chez
les gens une star aller chez les gens
envoient une surprise oui on va vous
montrer des images
ouais vous l'avez vu de l'intérieur vous
présentez espèces vidéo oui évidemment
regardé c'était des très très grand
moment imaginez vous êtes fan de bruel
vous avez dans son concert gros mais
chez vous il est donc salon pyrénées
vous chante je t'aime à bas
[Musique]
et attend
aucoin carré
[Musique]
lumières s'éteignent du orange
dans ce but
reste m
[Musique]
aux états plr
on partira ensemble une fois de plus
et la magie balle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout le temps
à
[Musique]
le toit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parler mieux que moi là les matrices
salle examen a eu au téléphone avec de
bourse entre amis bonsoir et merci
d'être au téléphone avec nous comme
plâtre en asie
tout le monde était vraiment bouge le
parce que à l'époque il faut repasser ça
dans le contexte était une émission
gigantesque à nous raconter oui c'était
une émission cygan telle qu'elle se
cachait à l'olympia c'est un dispositif
incroyable qui je souhaitais surtout une
émission qu'il ya de capter dans le
coeur des gens mais je pense que le
succès car elle sait que c'est une
émission sans faire part d un qu'il
était combien de fois où tu as tu as que
pleurer
c'est ridicule comme à moi je touche je
vous le mets qu'il allait bien forcément
c'est son ex femme
bonsoir comment allez-vous faire c'est
ridicule non blague à part moi je sais
que gt gt à tes côtés j'étais bord et on
est très très très envieux de cette
émission
d'abord il ya vers la relation avec avec
jean-luc crt à chaque fois des moments
incroyables
une sorte de rendez vous comme ça qu'on
ne voulait surtout pas raconte je pense
que cette émission en fait elle peut
mais à plusieurs éléments qui est
extrêmement forts s'étaient
effectivement changé c'est un producteur
à ce point là il m'avait un peu taillé
cette émission sur mesure et il tenait
aussi à une équipe qui n'avait qu'un but
c'est aussi de servir experts aider
et puis à des artistes qui se prêtait au
jeu à l'époque il serait il s'est quand
même le maire n'y avait pas les réseaux
sociaux on n'avait pas un spa g pour
être en contact ceux ci avec les gens
qu'on admire et est par conséquent on
permet finalement à des admirateurs de
toucher ordinaire et le ver encore petit
peser et ses cinq enfants pour que les
années
mais comme les stars étaient au même
numéro serre que les émotions et je
effectivement un marques et tous les
jours tous les jours on n'a pas tous les
jours
juste quand même pour l'anecdote après
le lancement on était ensemble je crois
du côté de la normandie à 9 heures à 9
heures 2 parce qu'à l'époque les patrick
chêne nous appeler à 9h02 pour des
scores généralement c'est un
accord-cadre les papes et croyez moi
c'était pas pensé mais là à 9h01
le téléphone a sonné la vie a décroché
le score était de combien la vie au nom
est mignon téléspectateurs 10 millions
de téléspectateurs
ce qu'on a vu parce que je sais qu'il me
dit oui c'était pourtant le pardon oui
non seulement il fusionne les voliges
engageant la laiterie était là mais s'il
échoue il ya aussi les gens dans la rue
en parler moi c'est bien sûr qu
absolument à faire j'ai réalisé ce jour
là que finalement on d'études va
s'appeler la veille il se souvenir
qu'elle s'était affirmée dié que le
sentiment et j'ai tous les jours on t'en
parle on doit forcément on se dit
pourquoi ça revient pas pourquoi ça
revient pas bah oui oui c'est vrai alors
qu'est-ce que tu réponds parce que je
sais qu'il ya des tentatives même du
vivant de deux ans lui vaut semble-t-il
et l'émission n'a jamais été au bout
pour la relancer sylla était unique et
je pense que personne il parfois de
faire cesser cette idée de faire un
deuxième épisode qui serait pas
forcément le bon et qui n'auraient pas
la saveur du premier et je pense que ce
star à domicile l'appel il était chez à
l'époque
à cette époque là aussi encore une fois
où les stars étaient assez inaccessible
ce star à domicile itunes et qu'on
pourrait pas leur faire aujourd'hui il
n'ya plus géorgiques les stars ne sont
plus les mêmes filles à d'autres
démissions se sont engouffrés dans ce
genre et on fait que peut-être aussi que
il a été un petit peu banalisé quoi donc
je ne suis pas persuadé que cette
émission pour avoir le même impact si
aujourd'hui elle mais elle tentée en
tout cas de renaître d'une autre façon
en tout cas merci au goût j'avais
d'avoir passé
l'histoire marqué les gens et je pense
que tu as marqué à jamais les français
grâce avec ce week-end des mois la
parole quand j'ai mon iphone c'est que
ce bordel mais moi mais tous les choses
disait maman tu mens créa stars à
domicile
j'en riais johnny qui parce que je
l'aimé comme ça avec ma mère c'est très
spécial
non mais on a tous rêvé et la commune
ont extrait on se met à pleurer voilà
moi j'ai eu la chance j'ai de la chance
de voir l'extrait de de bruyne avec xavi
avant l'émission et j'ai évidemment ce
n'est pas pour elle s'était excusé moi
excusez moi c'est la preuve qu'on peut
rater son mariage eric jalon du bord
[Applaudissements]